[Music]
the ark of the covenant
according to the hebrew bible it's an
ornate gold box supposed to have housed
two stone tablets containing the
original 10 commandments
as well as being a sacred artifact there
are several stories detailing its
immense power
used by the israelites in warfare to
destroy enemy armies and flatten entire
cities however at a certain point in the
biblical account it vanishes never to be
seen or heard of again
although many believe that it was
destroyed when a babylonian army
besieged jerusalem in 587 bce there's
evidence to suggest that it's still out
there waiting to be discovered some say
that it's in an undiscovered cave in the
judean desert sealed away for millennia
others claim to have actually seen it
and that it's safely kept in a church in
ethiopia yet others still so that it's
in the very place it went missing in an
underground vault deep below jerusalem
the whereabouts of this mythical hebrew
object continues to elude biblical
archaeologists it's often the subject of
wild and elaborate speculation with
entertaining yet unsubstantiated
conspiracies as to its current location
that's where i hope to come in i want to
investigate this matter carefully and
really separate the fact from the
fiction
so with that let's ask the question
is the ark of the covenant really lost
historically speaking the precise origin
of the ark is unknown
but the bible offers its own version of
events which can be found in the book of
exodus
after escaping slavery in egypt moses
and the israelites were camped out at
the base of mount sinai
then suddenly the earth shook and smoke
appeared on the mountain's summit and
the voice of god cooled out from above
he commanded moses to ascend the
mountain and there he stayed for forty
days and forty nights
when moses returned he carried with him
two stone tablets inscribed on them were
the ten commandments
these ten sacred laws constituted part
of the covenant a divine pact between
god and the nation of israel
the israelites will become a cherished
people of god provided they follow his
laws
shortly after god demanded that moses
construct a chest or ark to safely house
the two stone tablets he then gave a
very detailed description on how it is
supposed to look quote
have them make an arc of acacia wood two
and a half cubits long a cubit and a
half wide and a cubit and a half high
overlay it with pure gold both inside
and out and make a gold molding around
it
the description continues and the arc is
supposed to have two gold rings on
either side through which large poles
could be fitted so that it could be
carried inside the ark were placed the
stone tablets containing the ten
commandments elsewhere in the bible we
learned that it also stalled a jar of
manna the miraculous food substance that
appeared in the desert as well as a
wooden staff which belonged to aaron
moses's brother on the top of the ark
was an elaborate gold lid with two
cherubim facing one another the lid was
known as the mercy seat and it was the
holiest part of the ark it acted as a
throne for god who was said to appear
seated on it before moses and aaron
the ark was then housed in a great tent
known as the tabernacle only moses and
his brother aaron were allowed to enter
the innermost sanctum where the artifact
was safely kept there it was said that
they could communicate with god directly
taken as a whole the ark of the covenant
would have been a truly magnificent
thing to behold aside from its
decorative splendor it would have
represented god's physical presence on
earth as well as containing material
symbols of the sinai covenant
many biblical scholars and
archaeologists believe that the ark of
the covenant probably existed due to
these incredibly precise measurements
the bible offers it's likely that a
scribe was carefully measuring the ark
first hand and then proceeding to write
it down on parchment what's more the
practice of creating ornate ceremonial
arcs was widespread across the ancient
near east the ark of the covenant has
often been compared with ancient
egyptian procession barks which carried
statues of gods that were paraded around
cities or transported down the nile
with the discovery of the tomb of
tutankhamen in 1922
archaeologist howard carter saw a
chest-like object which he initially
thought was the fabled lost ark upon
further inspection however it was
revealed to be a gilded funerary box for
the young pharaoh the similarity to the
ark is indeed striking except that upon
this chest sat the god anubis who is
there to guide king tut into the
afterlife parallels to the ark of the
covenant can be found outside ancient
egypt this 9th century phoenician
sarcophagus housing the body of king
aharam depicts the storm god el sitting
atop a throne guarded by two cherubim
which bears a close resemblance to the
mercy seat on which the hebrew god is
supposed to appear
on a side note this levantine storm god
l is believed to be the precursor of the
biblical god who in hebrew is also often
referred to as l or more frequently in
the plural form elohim
these close connections to neighbouring
ancient cultures provide good evidence
that the ark of the covenant probably
existed in one form or another although
some of the more mythological elements
are of course debatable
in the biblical account when it came
time to travel the ark was carried by
the priests it always went one kilometer
before the people and would emit a
column of smoke that would guide the
israelites through their 40 years
wandering the desert when they finally
arrived in the promised land under
moses's successor joshua the ark
miraculously separated the river jordan
allowing the israelites save passage
just like moses had done to the red sea
all those years ago
however if anyone handled the ark that
wasn't supposed to they would meet a
terrible fate for soon revealed the ark
had fearsome destructive powers
in the book of leviticus two of moses
nephews sneaked into the tabernacle and
made an unauthorized offering to the ark
only priests were permitted to do this
so the ark set the two men on fire
burning them to a crisp
elsewhere in the bible there's an
instant where the ark is carted off to
jerusalem the oxen in front stumbled and
the ark wobbled to prevent it from
falling off the driver briefly steadied
the ark with his hand
big mistake for it kills him instantly
perhaps the most cataclysmic event is
when the ark is brought to a town called
beth shemesh out of curiosity the
townsfolk look inside as you'd expect
such a transgression would not go
unpunished
the town is quickly engulfed in a fiery
inferno the death toll varies but in one
manuscript it's at fifty thousand and
seventy
[Music]
learning of the ark's incredible power
the israelites see its potential as a
deadly weapon its most famous use could
be found in the book of joshua where it
is used to bring down the walls of
jericho during the siege the ark was
processed around the city walls whilst
horns were sounded this happened once a
day
on the seventh day everyone was
instructed to shout simultaneously in
doing so the city walls collapsed and
the israelite army came flooding in to
slaughter the city's inhabitants
following god's law
no one was to be spared
the ark of the covenant was some kind of
biblical superweapon the israelites
brought it to a number of battles in
order to unleash its devastating power
upon their enemies
the ark did not always guarantee victory
however in one story it gets captured by
the philistines and is taken away to
their capital ashdod there it's placed
before a statue of their god daegon
angered at this the ark destroys the
statue and then releases a horrific
bubonic plague upon the city's
population
fearing the ark the philistines rushed
to offer it back to the israelites who
gratefully accept their request
you can see how all these bible stories
about the ark of the covenant inspired
the 1981 film raiders of the lost ark in
the film the nazis seek to use the ark
as a weapon aware of its destructive
powers
in the dramatic climax they finally get
hold of it and prise it open but in a
gory use of melting wax prosthetics
they're all met with a grisly fate
it's good to see that hollywood is up to
scratch with all their biblical research
the ark causes all the devastation you'd
come to expect of it
once the israelites had settled in the
promised land the ark was eventually
placed in a permanent home
the temple when the building was finally
completed by king solomon the ark was
placed in a sacred inner chamber known
as the holy of holies
once a year on the festival of yom
kippur or the day of atonement the high
priest would be permitted to enter the
sacred room
there he would transfer all the nation's
sins onto two small goats and then
sacrifice them upon an altar proceeding
to sprinkle the blood upon the mercy
seat
this incidentally is the origin of the
term scapegoat you're welcome
the final mention of the ark is not as
destruction or theft but how its
caretakers were told to move it back to
jerusalem after it spent some time away
from the temple
this event took place during the
passover in the 18th year in the reign
of king josiah which places us roughly
in the spring of 621 bce
this is the last known sighting of the
ark after which it is never mentioned
again disappearing entirely from the
biblical narrative
the sudden disappearance of the ark
takes place just before jerusalem is
beset by disaster
about 35 years later in 587 bce the
neo-babylonian empire besieged jerusalem
under the command of king nebuchadnezzar
ii the conquering army set everything
ablaze the temple was ransacked and
destroyed much of the population was
killed but those who survived were
captured and sent away to babylon
forbidden from returning home
there they endured great turmoil as many
were forced into slavery
this lasted for 70 years marking a dark
period in jewish history known as the
exile
after the exile when the jews eventually
returned to their homeland and rebuilt
the temple there are no references to
the ark it doesn't seem to have been
there anymore even when this second
temple was eventually destroyed by the
romans in 70 ce there's no mention of
the ark being taken
a contemporary jewish writer flavius
josephus offers an itinerary of things
stolen but the ark is missing quote
the golden table of the weight of many
talents the candlestick also that was
made of gold and the last of all in the
spoils was carried away the law of the
jews there is no direct mention of the
ark although some have taken that last
phrase the law of the jews as a hidden
reference to it to me it seems a bit
unlikely as in the roman forum today
there's a triumphal arc depicting this
very incident
you can see all the treasures of the
temple including that golden candlestick
but no ark
this is unusual for such a valuable and
significant treasure it would have
deserved some sort of representation
either by the romans or by josephus
all lines of inquiry point back to the
babylonian siege of jerusalem in 587 as
the date the ark officially goes missing
it's likely that the disappearance of
the ark in the bible is somehow
connected to this babylonian invasion
and the destruction of the temple
in the talmud a collection of jewish
writings the rabbis assume that the ark
of the covenant was properly destroyed
that day
either when the temple burnt down and
collapsed or when it was carted away to
babylon
this is possible but is also an
assumption nowhere does it explicitly
say that the ark of the covenant was
indeed destroyed that day
with this lack of evidence it raises a
near infinite number of other
possibilities
perhaps the ark was hidden somewhere
safe before the arrival of the
babylonians
or perhaps it was never even there in
the first place
it may be out there today
waiting to be discovered
these possibilities we turn to now
with such a famous and high-profile
artifact like the ark of the covenant
there are several theories as to its
current location
some are better than others so i've
narrowed it down to three of the most
plausible
some early jewish sources say that it
was hidden in a safe location somewhere
in the judean desert
one of these is the second book of
maccabees
you won't find this book in all bibles
it's what's known as an apocryphal text
in the centuries after the babylonian
exile
new biblical texts were composed
examples include the book of jubilees
and the book of enoch
since they lacked the long history of
tradition that books like genesis or
exodus enjoyed their canonical statist
has not quite been agreed upon the
second book of maccabees is one of these
apocryphal books believed to have been
written somewhere between 150 and 120
bce
the book describes how just before the
babylonian invasion the prophet jeremiah
had a premonition that the ark would be
destroyed and so decided to hide it in
the wilderness the book says that
jeremiah took it to quote the mountain
where moses had gone up and had seen the
inheritance of god
this has been thought to refer to mount
nebo in jordan the mountain from which
moses saw god's promised land in the
book of deuteronomy although this is far
from certain
after hiding the ark in a cave at the
base of the mountain along with some
other temple paraphernalia jeremiah
closed off the entrance
some of his followers wanted to mark the
site so that they could find it later
but the prophet stopped them from doing
so saying quote the place shall remain
unknown until god gathers his people
together again and shows his mercy
this somewhat cryptic biblical prophecy
has not stopped many intrepid
gravediggers from making illegal
excavations around mount nebo hoping to
find the ark to which the jordanian
government monitors closely and
prosecutes heavily for sanctioned
archaeological digs much has been found
nearby the mountain but no secret cave
containing the lost ark of the covenant
this has prompted archaeologists to look
at other mountains featured in the bible
hoping to find the ark there instead
particularly mount sinai the place where
moses received the ten commandments
problem is however no one actually knows
where the original mount sinai is
supposed to be and so a whole other
investigation gets underway
most say that the biblical mount sinai
is jeber musa in egypt this tradition
goes back to the 6th century ce when
christians built a monastery near the
base of the mountain but there's
evidence to suggest that the actual
mount sinai may be elsewhere here are
all the possible locations that have
been put forward for the biblical mount
sinai you can see that we're dealing
with a very large geographical area
covering parts of egypt saudi arabia and
jordan
any one of these locations could have a
cave holding the ark of the covenant
assuming of course that it hasn't
already been discovered
one writer suggests that the ark of the
covenant was already found during the
crusades by a group of knights known as
the templar
according to this theory these knights
were camped out near the ruins of petra
jordan having heard that the ark may be
hidden somewhere nearby they began to
search the area eventually arriving at a
mountain called jebel al-madba at the
base of this mountain they reportedly
stumbled across an unmarked cave
lighting their torches they ventured
inside glinting in the torchlight lay
golden treasures and ancient ornaments
that had presumably remained undisturbed
for thousands of years but at the back
of the cave they found what they'd been
looking for
the ark of the covenant
from here it's been said that the
templars brought their treasures back to
europe but they remained secretive about
the ark of the covenant which they
jealously kept for themselves
some believe that it went to chartres
cathedral in france others say it went
to the estate of the english nobleman
ralph de sadly others still said that it
was taken to ireland and then shipped
off to the emerging american colonies
these stories raise some interesting
possibilities but as much as i'd like to
believe in them it's difficult too
you see there's not a lot of valid
evidence behind these theories it's
primarily speculation relying on some
pretty dubious source material as such
these theories are typically dismissed
by most historians and deemed to be the
work of controversial and fringe writers
returning back to our initial position
that the ark was supposedly hidden in
the judean desert one thing that is
really going for this theory is that
significant archaeological finds
continue to be discovered in this region
particularly in desert caves
in 1946 two bedroom shepherds were
herding their goats near some ruins by
the dead sea
noticing small caves on the cliffside
they climbed up to have a look in the
caves they found a collection of small
clay pots breaking them open they found
a series of delicate scrolls and
manuscript fragments they had been
incredibly well preserved due to the hot
desert climate and the ancient hebrew
was still legible
what was unknown to them is they had
made the most significant archaeological
find in biblical scholarship to this
date
it's currently believed that these
scrolls belong to a jewish sect known as
the essenes who hid these pots right
before their community was attacked by
the romans rather similar to how the
book of maccabees said that the prophet
jeremiah hid the ark shortly before the
babylonian invasion
just like the caves containing the dead
sea scrolls lay unexplored for thousands
of years there may be other caves out
there waiting to be discovered if the
stories are to be believed then the ark
of the covenant may be inside one of
them
unless however that the ark was never
hidden in the desert in the first place
but instead taken to africa
as this next theory shall explore
[Music]
for centuries a group of christians in
aksum ethiopia have claimed to be in
possession of the ark it's allegedly
being held in a small chapel but no one
is allowed to see it
the story as to how the ark may have
ended up in ethiopia can be found in the
kebra nagast a sacred chronicle of the
country in one story it claims that king
solomon and the queen of sheba had a son
together whom they named menelik
although he was raised in jerusalem when
he reached adulthood menelik had to
return to the land of his mother's
origin
ethiopia before he left however some of
malek's priests sneaked into the temple
and secretly stole king solomon's most
precious object
the ark
they replaced it with a flawless copy
impossible to differentiate from the
original
on his journey home menelik discovered
that the ark was with him but was
surprised to see that no one had been
harmed by its infamously destructive
powers not even the priests who had
taken it
interpreting this as a sign from god he
brought it back to ethiopia and placed
it in the holy city of aksum
legend has it that it's been there for 3
000 years and can be found in a small
chapel at the church of our lady mary of
zion it's been guarded by an unbroken
line of monks who are forbidden to leave
the chapel grounds
no one from the outside world is allowed
to enter
despite this there are some out there
who have claimed to have been inside the
chapel and have seen the ark with their
own eyes british historian edward
ullendorf a professor of ethiopian
studies in london is one of them in an
interview he revealed to have been shown
it secretly in 1941 while stationed
there during the second world war
however he did not believe that it was
genuine having inspected the ark for
himself he described it as quote
a wooden box but it's empty middle to
late medieval construction when these
were fabricated ad hoc
since this revelation scholars have
doubted the claims the ark really is in
ethiopia
they regard the story of king menelik as
an attempt at national myth-making and a
way for ethiopian monarchs to justify
their right to rule
many ethiopian christians vehemently
deny these claims maintaining that the
true ark really is in their possession
to my mind what would prove beyond a
doubt that the ark really is in ethiopia
would be if it was finally shown to the
world dispelling all the rumors claiming
it's a hoax this actually nearly
happened in 2009 when patriarch abu ne
paulos stated to the foreign press he
would finally unveil it unfortunately
however he retracted his offer the next
day
as of now the ark of the covenant
supposedly remains in this ethiopian
chapel until the ark is shown to the
world voluntarily or it is taken by
force as some have feared recently this
line of inquiry remains unresolved
[Music]
for this final theory we'll be returning
to the holy land back to the city where
our search began
jerusalem
some believe that the ark was hidden
underneath the temple on the site on
what's today known as temple mount
in the 12th century ce jewish scholar
and philosopher maimonies claimed to
know the whereabouts of the ark
he wrote that whilst building the temple
king solomon had a warning from god that
one day it would all be destroyed
including the treasures it was designed
to protect as a precaution king solomon
allegedly constructed a network of
maze-like vaults so that the ark could
be safely kept underground the account
continues to state that king josiah who
reigned during the last mention of the
ark in the bible used these underground
chambers to secretly house the ark
before the arrival of the babylonians
as it was located safely underground it
would have survived the collapse of the
temple above but as it was never seen or
heard of again perhaps no one came to
collect it
and it may be still down there today
even if you don't believe in the story
offered by maimonies there are a number
of rumors that are indeed underground
chambers beneath temple mount writing
roughly a thousand years before my
modneys jewish historian flavius
josephus wrote about certain royal caves
underneath the city of jerusalem that
were used to escape the romans that's an
unusual descriptor royal it seems to
hint to the idea that some of these
caves were built during the reign of
israelite kings in modern times a number
of underground networks have actually
been discovered across jerusalem in 1854
archaeologists discovered a disused
quarry that ran beneath part of the old
city's muslim quarter
named zedekiah's cave it covers an area
of about five acres and it's the largest
cave network discovered beneath the city
since then archaeologists have mapped
out a whole subterranean network
underneath jerusalem
some of these like the siloam tunnel
date somewhere around the 9th to 8th
century bce roughly the same time in
which king solomon is supposed to have
reigned but there's one place that has
not been explored properly the area
underneath temple mount
the reason why no excavations have been
carried out beneath temple mount is
because there are a number of sacred
structures that lie on top of it the
most prominent of which is the dome of
the rock
initially completed in 962 ce the dome
is a beautifully decorated islamic
monument that enshrines the rock where
the prophet muhammad is believed to have
ascended to heaven the dome of the rock
as well as the nearby alaksha mosque are
built atop temple mount upon the site
where solomon's temple is believed to
have stood
just below temple mount is also the
western wall the last surviving portion
of the second temple that was destroyed
by the romans this wall is considered to
be the holiest place in judaism
performing an excavation on temple mount
would be controversial it would risk
upsetting a number of religious groups
as archaeological work beneath these
structures could cause damage or even
collapse
this hasn't stopped some however from
trying
on the 28th of july 1981 a dispute broke
out near the western wall it had been
discovered that someone had been
performing an unlicensed dig beneath
temple mount this someone was rabbi
yehuda getz he had been trying to find
the ark
having been warned not to getz had
organized a secret excavation beneath
temple mount the dig took place during
the cover of night and shortly into
proceedings a small opening was
discovered behind which lay a large
tunnel
28 meters long and 6 metres wide the
newly discovered tunnel was believed to
connect to a number of chambers
underneath temple mount as a small
archway was discovered near the end getz
was sure that behind this lay the final
resting place of the ark
before more work could be done news
about it was leaked on an israeli radio
station shortly after large crowds on
either side of the religious divide
gathered outside and a fight broke out
the dig was banned and further
excavations were cancelled by
authorities since then the chambers
beneath temple mount remain closed off
as you may be aware from recent
political events in jerusalem the
situation is still very tense so for the
time being a systematic excavation on
temple mount is strictly forbidden
whatever may be lying underneath temple
mount continues to be out of reach
in recent years however there have been
some new non-destructive methods to get
glimpses as to what's beneath temple
mount
one pioneering method is ground
penetrating radar or gpr
using high frequency radio waves it maps
out subterranean surfaces and then
generates a blurry image
an advantage of this technique is that
it's non-invasive
nothing needs to be dug up or damaged
however even the slightest amount of
interference can manipulate the image
this can be caused by electricity or
certain rocks and in the ancient capital
city of jerusalem there's plenty of both
as archaeological digs are not allowed
to happen anytime soon this could be the
best way to finally locate the lost ark
of the covenant
nearing the end of our investigation
we're left with three theories as to the
ark of the covenant's current location
one the ark is hidden in a cave
somewhere in the judean desert if it
hasn't already been discovered
two
the ark is in a chapel in ethiopia
haven't been guarded there for thousands
of years
and three the ark is still in jerusalem
buried in a secret underground chamber
below the site of the original temple
each of these theories have their
individual merits and flaws but there's
one problem that they all have in common
all three of our stories are based on
written accounts that were composed many
years after the arc went missing the
apocryphal book the second book of
maccabees was written some 500 years
after the ark disappeared the ethiopian
chronicle the kebron aghast was likely
written in the 14th century ce
and the jewish scholar my modernities
who claim that the ark was hidden in
jerusalem lived in the 12th century ce
none of these accounts are eyewitnesses
we don't know where they got their
information from all we're working with
are anecdotes based on centuries and in
some cases millennia old rumors with
such a lack of reliable evidence
critical investigation inevitably turns
into speculation
it's also worth considering the
limitations of using the bible as a
piece of historical evidence while some
passages can be linked to known
historical events they are often
filtered through myth and written down
centuries after the events were supposed
to have happened it's difficult to know
where the truth ends and the mythology
begins
to try to get to the bottom of this
we'll need to go back and examine the
things that we do know to do that let's
rewind back to the original starting
point
we know that after the destruction of
the temple in 587 bce the ark is never
mentioned again in the bible i've
already mentioned that many have assumed
that the ark was destroyed during this
time and i've expressed my issues about
working on the basis of an assumption
but looking back perhaps i was too harsh
maybe the ark really is lost to history
during the exile after the babylonians
invaded in sac jerusalem the israelites
faced a crisis of religion with the
destruction of the temple and its sacred
artifacts god's physical presence on
earth was now gone for an ancient
israelite this would have been an
incredibly difficult reality to have to
come to terms with leading many to
abandon their ancestral beliefs yet it's
during this time of grief and mourning
when a number of changes begin to happen
in the religion of these ancient people
across the ancient near east a belief in
a deity was based on things you could
see
such as statues temples or arks
these things were now all gone and
belief began to move into something more
immaterial for the ancient israelites
god was not something you had to see in
order to worship it was just something
you believed in despite the lack of
physical evidence it is during this time
where the biblical texts were codified
and written down the ancient israelites
put faith in their shared stories
contained in their emerging holy texts
it is during this time where scholars
mark the end of ancient israelite
religion and the start of judaism
this seismic shift in religious thought
would have made sense if the ark was
indeed destroyed the cultic religion of
ancient israel had to adapt to the loss
of the material symbols of the covenant
perhaps then those claiming to know the
whereabouts of the ark are clinging onto
something that may have already been
lost
unable to move on from their grief they
hold on to the hope that the ark is
still out there
or maybe just maybe they know something
that we don't perhaps there is an
undiscovered cave out there in the
judean desert that contains the temple's
most valuable treasures or that the
chapel in ethiopia really does guard the
ark of the covenant and it's not an
elaborate hoax as some have suspected or
that the ark is safely hidden in a
subterranean chamber somewhere
underneath temple mount in the same
place it went missing all those many
years ago
if any of these theories are indeed
right on this and the ark of the
covenant really is out there waiting to
be found it would make for the greatest
discovery in archaeological history
however perhaps we should exercise
caution considering how dangerous this
artifact is supposed to be
perhaps some things are best left
undisturbed
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one if you'd like to
see more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
either way i look forward to seeing you
next time
goodbye